let's see where else we can go
why not um
oh i don't know what about maybe steve
from illinois
steve from illinois yes you're on the
air
can you hear me all right i can
uh i was just wondering were you
thinking of the recent
uh story um about biden opening up the
pipe the russian pipeline for germany
oh i i haven't even been following it
did he say he wants to do that
uh reports are saying that he's leaning
towards uh
lifting the restrictions or the
sanctions on it to open it back up
i did not see that i'll have to i wish i
could say i don't i don't know enough
about it i'm gonna have to check on that
oh good what's your opinion oh okay go
ahead yeah
oh sorry uh i was i just i just find it
i i don't know i find it kind of odd i
don't know
much information on it it seems kind of
like an odd move
uh i'd move to me i don't know i'm not
saying there's anything nefarious it
just seems like a weird move
i'll i'll research it and follow up um
the only other
kind of question i had is um again i
listen to your show i'm more like right
leaning but i was like listen to your
show because i feel like you're
very intelligent and kind of know what
you're talking about
um i understand you're you and your fans
hatred of fox but i'm just wondering
i mean if you watch cnn or msnbc they
like say a lot of nonsense as well
so is it like they understand there's
nonsense on both sides but they just
don't like the more the nonsense on fox
news or
do they fall in the line and not realize
that like
a lot of major cable news networks are
spewing a lot of nonsense
well as far as my audience is concerned
you'd have to ask them my view is that
certainly msnbc and cnn have corporate
bias and they have advertiser bias and
they have a lot of the types of bias
that that exist
but they are not promoting you know just
out and out
conspiracy stuff like having guest after
guest for two months making completely
bogus claims about the election
or pushing hydroxychloroquine for months
even when
uh you know a randomized controlled
trial say it doesn't work on coronavirus
it's just a different it's a different
caliber altogether but i think that
there's many criticisms of cnn and msnbc
they're just different than that of fox
oh okay okay yeah that's uh totally
understandable
i mean i i mean i see i guess different
levels of conspiracy slash like
stuff on the on those other shows i
guess just from my side
on things but like what's a conspiracy
from cnn
um
try it i like sorry i don't have one on
top of my head i know like watching it i
mean
the i'm not gonna like i know sciences
but i mean they were going on a hole
when the
cdc was talking about lifting the mass
mandates i know a bunch of
i mean i watched jory talk about how
she's wearing two masks when she
uh runs outside on there to wear masks
when you're vaccinated even though the
cdc was coming out and saying you don't
need to wear that so it just seems like
they're going anti-science from what the
cdc is going in
okay yeah she's on msnbc i think i mean
i i would be interested in seeing that
if that's what she said
then that would be not in line with the
science but i think it's different than
saying like you know
take hydroxychloroquine i mean cnn had
uh
governor cuomo on praising him and then
there's all these reports about the
nursing homes and everything like that
not questioning him on anything on that
okay i don't know the timing of that you
know we covered the nursing home scandal
when i learned of it i'm not saying i'm
not saying i'm not saying you i'm not
yeah no i got it
i'm not saying to you yeah like i said i
mean listen there's fair criticisms of
msnbc and cnn and the two you just
pointed out if you're describing them
accurately and the timing is as you
describe
i would be on board with you on those
criticisms
okay no i was just trying to see what
you thought of if you thought there was
any criticisms on the other side i know
you kind of focus on fox but
yeah kind of seeing if you saw any
criticisms on the other side
the two the two that you're mentioning
if they are as you describe i probably
would agree with you
i appreciate your time david thank you
all right thank you so much see
reasonable caller we're getting along
with a right winger it's all great
all right everybody thank you for
calling in i cannot get to any more
calls today
but i will take more calls soon thank
you